what's going on guys this is rob a lot
of you guys have asked me to make a
video about king the conqueror and that
makes sense he's a pretty complicated
character and the purpose behind this
channel is to make you an expert on
complicated things right to make them
simple to understand and so before we
get into actually explaining king what i
want to do here is i want to take a
minute and explain the relationship
between king the conqueror
and other characters or other versions
of king like rama tut kida mortis
immortus himself
iron lads scarlet centurion different
things along those lines the reality is
all those different characters are
basically versions of
k they are all rooted from what you
could call kang prime that's what marvel
calls them anyway
so here's what i want you to do i want
you to imagine that at the time that
we're recording this video july 1st
2021 i want you to imagine that you
somehow found a way to go back into the
past
and you went back to the year 1901 and
you crafted an entire
life for yourself right you made up a
new name gave yourself a new identity
all that kind of stuff
and while you do know that you actually
come from july 1st
of 2021 as time progresses that becomes
your personality that becomes you
right that becomes who you are as a
human being that's basically how the
relationship between
kang and the other versions of himself
work and we'll make more sense of this
as we kind of go through but there are a
few different places where kang's origin
is found now one of the more popular
ones that people cite which in reality
i think over complicates things it's
fantastic four issue number 273
and what this does is kind of establish
the identity of kane the conqueror as
being nathaniel richards from the main
marvel universe that he basically ended
up going into the future and kind of
ending up in an alternate reality of
sorts that was designated as earth 6311
where humanity had never experienced the
dark ages and then found themselves
involved in what was called a lunar war
now the way this worked is that because
society had never experienced
the dark ages that there wasn't really
any kind of suppression of science and
technology so humanity was far more
advanced in this alternate reality than
it is right now
and what this did is it actually led to
humanity basically developing colonies
on the moon now as time progressed these
colonies formed their own governing
bodies and in turn
defected from earth they quite literally
seceded from the planet earth
and so this sparked what was in reality
a civil war among humanity and basically
left humanity in an almost completely
extinct state
especially when it came to science
technology different things along those
lines nathaniel richards ending up in
this future basically allowed him to
become a kind of savior by bringing
humanity back from the from its near
extinction
and then kind of ushering in what was
essentially a golden age of science and
technology and so while that is kind of
a cool origin in and of itself the
reality is it's not really necessary
instead probably the best origin that
you could go with is in avengers issue
number 269 which makes sense because
kane the conqueror originally appeared
in avengers at number 8 and 1964 by stan
lee and jack kirby so the way this
origin played out is we were basically
told that at some future point in time
kane the conqueror or nathaniel that's
what you want to call it had basically
come across a future version of himself
who was in effect king the conqueror
right this conquering individual who's
moved across the time stream and all
that kind of stuff and a desire to keep
from becoming that guy what he had done
was kind of gone through a series of
escapades which led to him becoming
iron lad kinamortis different things
like that the important thing about this
is
in this in his true form and in terms of
how kang became who he was
the king basically got bored with the
with the reality he was living in which
was basically a peaceful earth there
wasn't really any conflict there was no
struggle or strife
people were able to live complete and
fulfilling lives and a desire to find
more satisfaction from his life
specifically
by basically conquering things he ended
up creating a time traveling machine for
himself in the form of a sphinx and then
traveled back into the past and adopted
the moniker of rama tut now ramat
becomes a little complicated here and
the reason why is because while he did
initially have this particular part of
his origin over the years in marvel
comics they've released stories that
have built on that the original
appearance of rama todd and the
fantastic four's involvement with him
was a fantastic four facing off against
ramitat after having been time displaced
themselves
over the years marvel has released
stories like the rise of apocalypse
which has basically tied the origin of
the villain apocalypse
into ramatat different things along
those lines there have been stories that
have involved west coast avengers and
things like that that also involve
ramatat
honestly those are unnecessarily
complicated just because of the fact
that those stories don't necessarily
have anybody
interacting directly with the fantastic
four and ramatan himself outside of like
apocalypse or maybe doctor strange or
somebody like that now of particular
importance with this particular action
of rahmatut was really built on with the
idea of of the rise of apocalypse in the
sense that as most comic book fans know
apocalypse is by all standards of
measurement a demigod right his
natural power is immortality as well as
the ability
to take on mass so to have some high
level of durability in the future he
made a pact with the celestials that
allowed him to use their technology and
that's where apocalypse basically gained
the ability to have pretty much any
superhuman power
outside of universal or even planet-wide
reality warping but kang the conqueror
in the future had come to the
realization that that was where
apocalypse began to rise to power
and believed that he could use
apocalypse as a pawn if you were to
capture him at an early enough age and
then basically brainwash him and induct
him into becoming an
agent of kang and then helping kang to
basically conquer the world that's why
he went back to the point of being rama
tut because if he could go back
far enough then it'd be easier for him
to conquer humanity just because egypt
at that point in time was still in a lot
of ways kind of the cradle of
civilization and so ultimately being
defeated by the fantastic four
led to king fleeing back or at least
trying to go back to his own timeline
only to end up in the 40th century now
being caught in this future point in
time basically led to the kind of
fantastic four origin you saw in 273
which went a little bit further and then
actually had him essentially conquering
the world and then after conquering the
world expanding outward and then
conquering all these different worlds
that exist
across the universe and then finally
conquering the universe itself
in the far-flung future the biggest
issue with this is that if we look at
something like avengers issue number 267
this introduced the idea that while
there is king prime
in the future every time he goes into
the past
and does something in the time stream
he's basically creating an alternate
reality and that alternate reality
has its own version of kang with its own
campaigns and its own desires and its
own experiences right so
which event that king is engaged in
takes part in the main marvel universe
versus an alternate reality universe
really just depends on what story marvel
wants to write so if you go back and you
look at avengers number eight when he
originally appeared
and kang fought against the avengers
that he lost against the avengers in
that story but because he went back in
time and fought the avengers there's now
an alternate reality where kang
won against the avengers right or
there's an alternate reality where he
killed all the avengers instead of
defeating them and imprisoning captain
america right just things along those
lines that's kind of how that works and
as you guys could probably imagine all
these possibilities creating all these
different universes
basically have all these versions of
kang in these universes who have just
done
different things that's important
because in the future marvel would
actually use that
to create something called the council
of kings now one of the big
issues that marvel created when it came
to kang is creating something called
divergent kings and so if ever kane goes
back into the past and just creates an
alternate
reality by virtue of just doing anything
what marvel also did is they said even
in the main marvel universe there are
different versions of kang
the reality is i ignore that because i
think it just over complicates things
makes it unnecessarily complicated and
it doesn't really serve any useful
purpose i mean you have characters like
victor timely who's basically just a
version of kang
uh who is considered to be divergent
honestly i think it's unnecessary so in
truth you can just ignore that right
especially because it largely is
contained the events of avengers forever
which is the story that
marvel and fans just haven't referenced
in forever because it doesn't really
matter probably one of the biggest and
most notable moments especially for
those of you guys who are coming from
the uh from the loki tv show came in a
combination of different stories uh the
first one
came with avengers issue number 23 then
you go into thor annual issue number 17
and despite what i just said avengers
forever issue number nine
and you had the introduction of a
character named princess ravana
rinslayer now she
is incredibly important to the entirety
of the king mythos so the idea behind
this was that despite king the conqueror
ruling this particular point in time
there were other kingdoms who existed on
earth now all of them were largely
subservient to kang or
just outright subservient right in the
sense that he just straight ruled him
with an iron fist
and kang was kind of a dick right like
he ruled in a pretty hardcore way
but ravana rinslayer had a father named
uh king corellius and the whole point
behind this was that he was in love with
ravana rinslayer and so the bargain that
was made
is that because of his love for her he
would allow her father to kind of rule
with autonomy in the sense that he would
answer to kang
but king would also allow him a lot of
leeway in terms of how he ran his own
kingdom
and wouldn't really micromanage anything
but the other part of this is that
because
kang loved ravana rinslayer the idea was
he tried to pressure her into marrying
him now ultimately she rejected him and
this led to kane the conqueror snatching
up the avengers and then bringing them
to that point in time
and then trying to defeat them as a
display of his kind of
masculinity i guess or his capabilities
to ravana
in the hope of winning her heart
ultimately it didn't work now the big
thing about this this is probably one of
the most significant moments to happen
in this story is that because kane the
conqueror
had shown kind of a softness or kindness
to ravana rinse layer
and because of the fact that in a chance
where he could have killed the avengers
he chose not to
and actually chose to simply let them
survive that one of his members or at
least
a member of his army by the name of
baltag had seen this as a sign of
weakness and baltac had long since been
trying to use serp control of kang's
armies by killing kang himself and
attempted to do so he tried to launch a
rebellion it was initially quashed
eventually he broke free and when he
tried to kill kang
ravana jumped in the way now she didn't
necessarily die per se
but with her throwing herself in front
of kang was really kind of display
of how much she cared about kang right
how much she actually had kind of fallen
in love with king now ball tag was
killed right king just had him executed
and so what ended up happening is king
the conqueror had actually found a way
to put ravana in a kind of suspended
animation where she was never really
alive
and never truly dead she just kind of
existed there until such a time as he
could find a way to basically bring her
back
now something that i do want to specify
here is the nature of a mortise right
something that i said we would kind of
gloss over over the course of this video
so immortus is the future end result of
king right a mortise is what king will
become think of it like
king's final form more or less that's
kind of how immortus works
the biggest issue with this is that
immortus looks at kang
and sees kang just running throughout
the entirety of the time stream and
spawning a whole litany of alternate
reality versions of himself and the
concern of immortus was that if this
continued to happen that eventually
one king would rise up or possibly all
the kings would band together
and destroy immortus and immortus wanted
to be the last version of kang to
exist and so in order to ensure this
happened that what ended up taking place
is that in an alternate reality that
there was a version of kang that had
kind of gone through
and looked at the history of really the
multiverse itself and came to the
realization
there was a universe where the events of
of ravana renaissance are dying had not
played out yet
and so what he had done is that
alternate reality version of kang had
taken ravana rinslayer from the other
alternate universe and that other
alternate universe version of kang had
basically died right this was all kind
of a manipulation by the hand at the
hands of a mortis in order to
remove one of the kings across the
multiverse and that's happened multiple
times there have been a lot of instances
where stories have played out
that alternate reality versions of kang
have died at the hands of mechanation
schemes of a mortise or even by a
mortise's own hands
to reduce or control the number of kings
that exist
across the multiverse to make sure that
kang does not become a credible threat
to the existence of a mortise himself
one of the more important elements of
kang's history right kind of focusing
back on the main marvel universe version
of kang one of the more important
elements of its history came as
something called the game of galaxies
now the game of the galaxies was a
pretty significant crossover in marvel
comics right i can't really
you know overstate how important this
was and the reason why is because what
you had was the grand master and the
elders of the universe who had
approached kane the conqueror with the
possibility of finding a way to bring
ravana wren slayer back
but the only way they would do that is
if kang got himself involved in one of
the grand masters games and so what you
ended up getting was a grand master
creating something called the squadron
sinister now a lot of you guys have
probably heard of the squadron supreme
the squad of supreme is by all standards
of measurement marvel's version of the
justice league and i would question
anybody who told me with a straight face
that it wasn't
and what grandmaster had done is that
after encountering the squadron supreme
in avengers number 69 that he had
desired to create his
own as part of a game with king the
conqueror and so he ended up just
grabbing a whole bunch of different
people and then basically turning them
into what were
in essence an evil version of the
squadron supreme and then in turn
challenging kane the conqueror and kane
the conqueror had to assemble his own
group of superheroes now the reality is
this was
long in coming because a lot of fans
wanted to see what it would look like if
the squadron supreme or some version of
the squadron supreme that was basically
evil
fought against the avengers the story
was cool and it was interesting for what
it was
but it had huge impacts on the character
of king and the reason why is because
the deal that was struck was that if he
defeated grandmaster he would have the
power over life
and death but because he experienced a
kind of draw in the first round
instead he was given the choice of life
or death and because of the fact that he
hated the avengers so much he chose to
kill the avengers but was ultimately
defeated
instead of bringing ren slayer back and
so ravana rensselaer basically stayed
dead that was important because it
focused on what you could call the human
element of king
basically making a poor decision and
then having to live with the
consequences of it but following that
there were a few different stories that
were kind of interesting here right you
had things like
fantastic four annual number 25 where
kane the conqueror was caught in what
was basically a time storm which was
another attempt by immortus to
uh to basically prune or to eliminate
some of the kings across the the
multiverse and that while this version
of kang was essentially lost in the time
stream and should have been dead instead
he just transferred his consciousness to
a new body that was the kind of things
that you you saw
unfolding there now one of the stories
that you saw coming out around this time
albeit an unnecessarily complicated
story which
i still have a hard time getting through
was the celestial madonna now celestial
madonna is one that
a lot of old school comic book fans know
about and they probably agree
probably one of single uh steve
engelhardt's more complicated pieces of
work but this has
had huge impacts on the marvel landscape
not necessarily just for kane the
conqueror
it did the idea of the celestial madonna
is that it would give that she would end
up giving birth to like the most
important person or possibly even the
most powerful person in existence who
would have control over time and space
and so naturally cain the conquerors
sought this person out in order to
basically mate with them and then have
this child that would have control over
time and space
the reality was it basically revolved
around mantis banging a tree it's really
all it was but it also had huge things
that were involved here right one of the
biggest things to come out of this
is this one you learned for the first
time in marvel comics that kane the
conqueror and mortis and rama tut were
all basically the same person
it was one of those kind of paradigm
shift stories that dealt with a lot of
different things but after celestia
madonna i'm not aware of any major
significant uh changes or or impacts for
the character of kang he appeared in a
lot of stuff right you know secret wars
different things like that but then you
get into the council of kings now
despite having appeared multiple times
over the years in marvel comics the
council of kangs is exactly what you
think it is
a whole bunch of different kangs who all
just kind of exist as a singular council
now in avengers 267 through 269 you
ended up having this event where pretty
much
all the kangs except for three of them
prime kang and two others
were wiped out by those three particular
kangs of course again this was all just
kind of a manipulation of the hands of a
mortis to reduce as many kings as
possible but it was also one of those
things where the concept of kang had
just become so unnecessarily complicated
and so many alternate versions of
himself that marvel just wanted to just
prune them all right they just wanted to
to literally cull as many kings as they
possibly could and it worked right they
ended up just reducing them down
by a huge number now in truth the actual
destruction
of pretty much all the variant versions
of kang or the other versions of kang
outside of
prime king didn't really come around
until fantastic four 339 through 341
which actually dealt with it being
called the black celestial and in
essence the black celestial had betrayed
the other celestials and so
in making its escape it basically
resurrected galactus after his
um pretty much near death at the hands
of terrax the tamer
and then increased galactus hunger at
the same time a time bubble was created
which would have essentially consumed
everything
if galactus hadn't done it based on his
own individual hunger and so by virtue
of a handful of different situations
all that ended up happening here is that
the ultimate nullifier was used to
destroy galactus and the time bubble
along with the with the black celestial
itself and the other versions of kang
were kind of pulled into this time
bubble and destroyed as well so it was
one of those stories where it largely
focused on the fantastic four
uh but marvel just kind of rolled the
other kings in it as well as a means to
just kind of reduce their number even
further kind of sending kang all the way
back to just being
one singular guy who exists out there
and so at that point all you had was
kang immortus and rahmatut and that was
it that's all you really had those three
guys which was
admittedly a lot easier to manage now
another story that king had which is one
that wasn't really well received i don't
think at the time that it came out but i
loved it uh was avengers the terminatrix
objective this story was not bad at all
and i thought it was it was pretty
interesting
this largely dealt with the return of
ravana wren slayer albeit in the form
of a character by the name of revelation
basically a future version of herself
who had actually
married kang and it was it was kind of
wonky it was a weird and wonky story but
the important thing behind this is she
actually ended up kind of going back to
the past and then
sort of showed up in the present day and
just kind of resided there actually
allied herself with the avengers to try
to take out a version of kang but the
bigger things about this outside of
stuff like preston john which was a
weird story arc in and of itself any old
school comic book fans will tell you
that's true
one of the other things that went on is
it actually introduced and really
focused on kane the conqueror
in relation to other organizations that
were out there specifically the time
variance authority now what was really
interesting about this is that despite
the fact that the council of kangs had
largely been destroyed
the realities or the universes that they
lived in and the
the universes they'd conquered were
still somewhat intact
and this kind of elevated king prime to
being this character that almost saw
what was in effect a multiversal empire
where he literally ruled
entire universes and what this did is it
stood
in direct contrast to the time variance
authority which sought to kind of
control the multiverse and so you ended
up finding out that like the empire of
kang was
massive in comparison to almost anybody
else outside of the tva the tva was huge
as well
but you also had things like the
coalition of realities and things along
those lines but
it was huge in terms of how it elevated
and moved king up to a much larger role
in so far as how he functioned on the
multiversal level now what was really
kind of interesting about this is that
by the time you got to the end and
especially when you got into avengers
forever and things like that that ravana
this alternate reality version of ravana
and and kang prime had actually kind of
put their differences aside
they've gotten back together again as a
couple they went back to the 40th and
41st centuries and they basically
ruled together and then ken got bored
and went back to basically take
take over his role as rama tut again it
was a little wonky but it was still kind
of cool
but one of the bigger things that came
out of this was king's relationship to a
mortise that again
if a mortise was a future version of
kang basically what he was guaranteed to
become
then the events of avengers forever
basically removed that and changed that
when kang came into direct conflict with
a time variance authority but the long
and short of this and really kind of the
quick explanation since we don't have a
ton of time left
it was basically severing the connection
between immortus and king
that kang was no longer guaranteed to
become immortus instead they were just
completely different characters now it
was a way for marvel to try to
make immortus a little more interesting
by removing him from just being the
guaranteed version of kang
to kind of solidify this idea that they
were individual characters that had
their individual stories and so on and
things could unfold with one without
directly impacting the other
uh so that was kind of interesting for
people who were kang fans but following
this one of the coolest things that
happened with kang really came in the
form of iron lad there is kang dynasty
but honestly that's probably a story we
should just do
because king dynasty would take us 10
minutes to explain
but iron lad is one of the cool things
there's a character we haven't really
talked about yet so i want to kind of
hit on him for a second in the early
days
of of marvel's kane the conquerors
stories they established this idea that
kang
had basically met a younger version of
himself when he was 16 years old
and that the desire was to ensure this
younger version of himself would
actually go on to become kink instead
the exact
opposite happened now the whole idea of
the introduction or the full-on
introduction of iron lad in the young
avengers was designed to actually
bookend into that old school origin that
was done back in the 1970s and so the
point behind this was that when
kang had gone to visit his younger self
iron lad and said like i'm the person
you're going to become
and my goal is to ensure that you stay
this way by actually protecting him from
bullies and so on and so forth
that iron lad actually swore a vendetta
to never become
king and that's why iron lad despite
being a version of kane the conqueror
is an enemy of kane the conqueror
because he's basically his teenage self
who never wants to become that version
of himself now the reason why avengers
forever was so important is because
it allowed stories like this to be
written which basically established that
iron lad is not guaranteed to become
kang
any more than kang is guaranteed to
become immortus it did offer a bit of
complication
because it brought in things like well i
mean are they like their own characters
now right if iron lads not guaranteed to
become kang then if he doesn't
does it just become an alternate reality
where he never becomes king marvel never
answers those questions
instead it's just kind of like he's his
own character now and able to do his own
thing but then you also went into the
story of the apocalypse twins now
the apocalypse twins were cool the
apocalypse twins were basically what
happened when one of apocalypse's
horsemen got with
the the horsemen archangel warren
worthington and then they had some kids
but the idea of the apocalypse twins in
relation to
to king himself is that he saw them as
what would become a credible threat to
his rule just because of the level of
power they possess
and much like he wanted to do with
apocalypse when he was operating his
rama tut the goal was to get his hands
on the apocalypse twins whisk him into
the future and basically turn them into
his servants to a degree and so during
uncanny avengers there was this amazing
moment when like the kids are born he
appears and then snatches them away and
like that's it right he basically just
disappears for a long time now they
eventually come back
and you do see some pretty cool stories
the death see different things along
those lines but the story as it unfolded
and uncanny avengers was amazing so here
is a crazy thing behind this right the
whole idea here
is kang like his motivation always has
been was to conquer all space and time
and he used the apocalypse twins to do
it and what they actually started doing
is they started going through and
wiping out all these different alternate
realities right these various worlds and
so on but kang was gathering people from
all these alternate futures that had
been obliterated now along the way
king's timeline itself had been wiped
out which actually took place uh back in
uncanny avengers issue number 12. but
the cool thing about this is you ended
up seeing like alternate reality
versions of strife
venom doctor doom and they were
basically referred to as kang's chrono
chord the whole just behind this was to
basically target
exotar the celestial and the idea here
was that with yarnbjorn having
previously been enchanted when thor
fought uh fought apocalypse and was
imbued with the ability to damage
celestials that with uh with kang and
the apocalypse twins getting their hands
on yarnbjorn it was used to attack
exotar and then in turn king
started absorbing all these cosmic
energies of exotar the celestial himself
which briefly allowed him to basically
really kind of control all of space and
time across the universe but with kang
on the verge of basically conquering
everything ultimately he was defeated by
a mortise and his infinity watch which
those of you guys who we call the
infinity watch are basically individuals
each of which possesses an infinity
stone as well as the avengers themselves
and so kang along with his chrono chord
just kind of disappeared into the time
stream
the reality is that kang as we knew him
basically began to vanish and the reason
why was because marvel was winding up to
secret wars so the next time that you
saw him and really the only time that
you saw him that was any real
significant measure here was during
original sin when captain america had
basically
get you know gained the the time stone
following its disappearance and the
destruction of the rest of the infinity
stones during the first incursion
that captain america had appeared in the
far-flung future
in front of iron lad immortus and king
and the reality is despite the fact that
the three of them all
hated each other they came to the
realization that captain america's quest
to stop the illuminati from destroying
incursive worlds would lead to the
collapse or the destruction of the
universe the captain america was
actually kind of
fast moving towards the end of things
now the reality of this was that there
was nothing anybody could do to stop the
collapse of the multiverse that's one of
the things that we learned
and so they took the infinity stone they
put it in a kind of no time space right
where
the time stone just simply wouldn't work
and then they intended to keep captain
america locked in the future so he
couldn't prevent
uh iron man and doctor strange and all
those guys in the illuminati
from destroying alternate worlds of
course captain america ended up breaking
the time stone free
went back to the modern era and then
that's where you basically pick up with
eight months later
when he is the head of shield and he's
hunting down all the different members
of the illuminati and then trying to
stop them right again at the end of the
day there was no way to stop the
collapse of the multiverse and the
incursion of worlds but that's basically
it right i mean there is a little bit
going on with kang i mean it does kind
of appear a few times here and there but
the reality
is that kang's one of these characters
where he was really really huge
back in the 70s 80s and kind of in the
early 90s and then by the time you got
to the mid to late 2000s he just kind of
dropped off so with that being said guys
hopefully
king the conqueror makes a lot more
sense to you all if you guys are
interested we could do a video on
immortus and iron lad and those
characters but thank you guys for
watching
and i will catch you all later peace